okay well so so far we've been talking
about regression trees the response was
quantitative salaries in this case of of
uh baseball players
um oftentimes trees are used when the
response is a categorical variable and
so then we call those classification
trees but you'll see the the technology
is very similar and we just have to
change the essentially the loss function
and how we measure
good performance so let's see how that
goes
so we're going to predict in a
classification tree um each observation
belonging to the most commonly occurring
class
so that's what's going to happen in the
in the terminal node of the tree as
instead of
just giving the prediction being the
mean we can classify to the most common
class
we're going to grow the tree in a very
same way as we did for class for
regression trees
but we don't use residual sum of squares
as a criterion for making the splits we
need a criterion that's more geared
towards classification
so one thing you can do is at each
internal node you can just look at the
classification error rate
and and that's easy to compute
so suppose
suppose
class
k
a bigger point so suppose you've got
capital k classes
and you compute the proportion
in the terminal node in each of the
classes from one up to capital k well
the class you're going to classify is
going to to is the class that's that's
got the largest of those probabilities
those proportions and the error you're
going to make is going to be 1 minus
that maximum right so all the ones that
don't belong to the maximal class are
going to be counted as errors so you
could use that to to
decide on the split
and so that's the proportion of errors
you're going to make
but it turns out that that's a little
bit jumpy and noisy and it's not very it
doesn't lead to a very
smooth tree growing process and for that
reason some other measures are
preferable
one measure is the genoi index
and it's a kind of variance measure
across the classes so you've got k
classes capital k classes often k is two
but not necessarily
and
this if for those who know the binomial
distribution this is each of the terms
is like a binomial variance and in fact
for the multinomial this is the diagonal
of the
these on the diagonal of the covariance
matrix so this this is a measure of
total variability
in the in that region
and if the genome index is really small
what that means is
pretty much one class is is favored and
all the rest are really small whereas in
the extreme case trevor if the region is
pure so it's all one class then the one
of those p hats will be one the rest
will be zero and g will be zero that's a
good that's a good point and and on the
other hand if i guess if they're all
equally distributed in the classes
this g9 index will be maximum
and and but it moves in
it changes in a smooth way
so that's one of the the criteria that
are very popular
um
and it
it's also known as a purity index it
measures the purity of the class
um an alternative is is the deviance or
cross enter entropy
and this is based on the binomial log
likelihood or the multinomial log
likelihood and it's a measure that
behaves rather similarly to to the genie
index and either of these are used and
and give very similar results
so let's look at an example we'll look
at the heart data
these data have a binary response
called hd there's 303 patients and
they're all represented with chest pains
so the outcome
has a value yes indicates the presence
of heart disease based on an
angiographic test what no means no heart
disease
for these data they're 13 predictors
amongst them age sex cholesterol
and other heart and lung function
measurements
and so we grew we ran the tree growing
process with cross validation
and
we'll see what we get in the next figure
at the top
you see the full tree grown to to all
the data and you can see it's quite a
bushy tree
with an early split split on fell it's
actually it's a it's a thallium stress
test a thalian stress test okay
and
and then
the two the left and right nodes were
split on on ca
calcium i think which is calcium
and and then the subsequent splits it's
hard to see here that you get these
pictures are in the book
so quite a bushy tree
and you see at the terminal nodes of of
this tree are
that the
classifications know all yes
so that means an observation that for
example ended up in this leftmost
terminal node here the majority in that
class were nose no heart disease and so
the classification produced would be a
no
whereas the right hand one year is a yes
interest in
this terminal node has two nodes
so if they both predicted no why was
there splittier at all
well it must mean that one of these
nodes is purer than the other so even
though they were both ended up having a
majority of nodes the one node was purer
than the other node and the g9 index
would identify such such a node
so this tree is probably too bushy and
so once again cross validation was used
and again we see in the right hand panel
the results of cross validation
and
we see
that the training error the test error
and the validation error
here we've actually looked at the
training error averaged over each of the
cross-validation folds
which is why
it's it's a little jumpy
and actually even increases in in one
point here because the trees and the
architecture of the trees are different
in each of the folds
the cross validation and and test error
we had a left out test set here as well
those curves look pretty much the same
and we end up seeing that a tree size of
around about six
um
tends to
to do well
these bars on these cross validation and
test curves are standard error bars so
there's quite a bit of variability here
the data set's not that big
and on the right here we see the prune
back tree
that's pruned back to size six of course
the prunion was again governed by the
the cost comp complexity parameter alpha
and this year will be a sub tree of of
the big tree grown
and that gave the best classification
performance which is estimated to be
around about
25 percent error in this case
in this in this figure we
we show we compare trees with linear
models trees aren't always the right
thing to do
and so to contrast that we look at two
different scenarios
in in this in these cartoons here the
the truth is indicated by these two
colors
in this top left panel the truth is
actually best depicted by a linear model
so the decision boundary in this case
between the two classes
is best given by a line
okay
and in this case a tree is not going to
do very well we see a tree a tree's
attempt to partition this space and you
know while it does a valiant job it just
doesn't do well enough because it's it's
confined to pick boxy regions right so
there'd be a split over here a split
over there and then this region was
subdivided then that region was
subdivided in an attempt to get
at this linear decision boundary so this
would be classified as as
as uh
beige
this would be classified as green beige
green and so on in a steppy in a steppy
fashion
on the other end in the lower in the
lower two panels the the optimal region
is
a blocky kind of partition region
and here a linear model is not going to
do well in the left panel we see the
best linear approximation to this
decision boundary and it's going to make
lots of errors because
you know with one single linear boundary
it's hard to approximate a rectangular
region like this and of course in this
one a tree will nail it
so it'll with two splits it can get the
decision boundary perfectly
so some problems are more naturally
suited to trees some problems aren't and
so the idea is we're going to think of
trees as one tool in our toolbox and
we'll we'll use it where appropriate but
of course we'll also bear in mind
simpler linear models
as well
so just to wrap up the section on trees
then uh we've seen some
there's advantages and disadvantages in
a sense they're simple if the trees are
are small not too many thermal notes
because they're easy to display and to
understand for non-specialists
and for example if we look back at this
heart disease tree right
the prune one on the bottom right
a doctor
might like this tree because it
it mimics in a sense the way his
decision making process might work and i
was trying to decide whether a patient
has heart disease he might first do an
initial test on based on thallium stress
test
and if they fail that test
then do a further test based on calcium
and decide about heart disease
if they if the test was
passed we might again do a calcium test
and then followed by some other criteria
so you stratify the population in a
series of simple rules to try to
determine whether patient is of high or
low risk so for that reason it's trees
are popular because of the their
simplicity and the fact that they they
mimic the way some people make decisions
as a series of
of uh
of splits
and they can they can just display in a
simple tree which means again they're
attractive because there aren't
equations to have to understand
they can also handle qualitative
predictors without the need to have to
create dummy variables
us some of the categorical variables can
be have more than two levels and we can
you can split a
categorical variable into two sets of
subcategories
so these are all good things the big
downside is that the um
they don't predict so well compared to
more state-of-the-art methods and we'll
see for example for the hard data that
the the predict the prediction accuracy
of a tree is not very good compared to
other methods
the other methods we'll talk about now
actually use trees but in an ensemble
they combine trees
they build
many trees on the same data and then
they average or combine them in some way
and in the process they improve the
prediction area substantially